yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
get protected at expressvpn comm / yang
I think Jo is gonna win but like then
that's just like the starting gun of
this epic amount of work we have to do
it's amazing it's like every week you
see we say to ourselves I can't believe
it got worse but it keeps there's so
many other things that keep happening
like wow and I do feel like you're your
other book the war of war on normal
people is a real thing it's gotten
that's gotten even worse - like the the
overlooking so many people and that are
in need of basic you know in need of a
basic income or an economic opportunity
like that's gotten even worse among all
the others among the big giant problems
that real basic life you know an
economic opportunity has gotten worse
it's one reason why I think Jo's gonna
win that 72% of Americans say this is
the worst time in American history in
our lifetimes I mean that's not exactly
like four more years material it's like
this is freaking awful so I think you
know I think we're gonna call an end to
the Trump era but then the whole still
gonna be there so you know I just I
haven't liked my shovel in my closet
metaphorically speaking and I'm just
like waiting to put the word - go out
and start digging here I got just to
speak to that since it's right here hold
on I've got a where is it it's right
here I've got a a literal trowel that I
was using to dig in the backyard for
treasure so you know in the woods so
that's where I'm at
a few days ago I interviewed SNL star
and head writer Colin Jost about his new
book a very punchable face at 6:00 than
I which is an art center synagogue
cultural center in DC the event was
virtual of course but had a great
conversation enjoyed it immensely hope
you do too this is yang speaks with
Colin Jost at 6th and I about his new
book a very punchable face let's all
give Colin Jost around of applause he'll
be able to hear you from your book is
phenomenal I enjoyed it immensely I've
been a fan of SNL since I can remember
so let's start with a title a very
punchable face you know I think most
people like find that funny
and there's like a theme of
self-deprecation throughout the book so
what were the what was the process
behind your deciding on a title because
I know the title of your first book is
actually kind of a big decision it is
it's like with music you put out an
album you could the first one can just
be your name you know it's easy no
that's just like the industry standard
you got a eponymous album but that you
know with books you got actually think
about it you know I want I also before I
start wanted to thank you I was very
honored that you that you agreed to do
this and talk to me and I'm a big fan of
yours and I think what you brought to
the campaign was such an elevated and
fresh set of ideas and you were just
really fun to watch and also you you you
like it was the only new ideas that were
out there and I really I I don't know I
gained like a whole new like idea of
what a candidate could be from watching
you and I hope that your ideas continue
and then you continue and
make them a reality because it was
really inspiring to see so thank you and
thank you for doing this because it
means a lot
I wrote about a lot of so there's a lot
of self-deprecating and humiliating
things in my book I really wanted it
always my book to be entertaining I
didn't want it to be trying to be overly
educational or pedantic in any way or I
didn't want it to be just taking weird
victory laps about anything or or just
like name dropping stuff I wanted it to
be stories that I thought were were you
know that were funny and that people
would would like reading and and I ran
everything through that filter and it
turns out a lot of those stories ended
up being ones where I was injured or
humiliated or emotionally abused or you
know just by my own dumb decisions got
injured or put in a terrible position
and I thought you know that would be
entertaining and it seems like people do
enjoy when I went when you know
injurious things happen to me well I I
confess that after reading your book
like you did start to resemble one of
those action movie heroes in my mind
where like you take your shirt off it
that there's like this scarf of that
this is from like the Google mishap this
is from the bike this is from the
surfing that I kind of figure in my mind
wow you you're also as we all know
you're engaged to like a superhero that
you know everyone's growing up with so
there's that that's another reason why
you seemed like an action hero I was no
superhero but also that's not so I
confess to being and this is one thing I
liked about your book too is that like
you know your book was very very
personal but like you said it wasn't
like a name-dropping type book it was
like personal about your childhood
personal about your formative
experiences which were very funny like
consistently I you know I feel like I
understand Staten Island better thanks
to your book and also
I happen to have seen king of Staten
Island you know relatively recently and
so like between that and your a book
like I feel like I understand the fifth
borough hopefully it's not an insult the
composit borough that's one of the
nicest things anyone's ever said about
that Island Staten Island we're part of
New York we swear and so you went from
stand down you went to high school in
the city which also had many many funny
and it certainly the most affecting very
very quintessentially New York story I
thought was the story of your mom and
her bravery during 9/11 and I was in New
York on that day like I remember when
the towers fell is a beautiful day in
terms of the weather like you know not a
cloud in the sky and then you hear that
a plane crash in the World Trade Center
and I was part of the crowd of thousands
that just started walking away from
downtown like I was near at the Empire
State Building I showed up to work and
then this happens and then everyone in
the office is like we should get the
heck out of here
and then we start walking north but your
mom did the opposite your mom actually
headed towards the towers which to me is
probably the most heroic thing I can
imagine doing having been on the island
that day like every human instinct is
like go away from from what is happening
and she actually went went towards it
yeah I mean it's I don't know how that
that instinct happens I think she she
you probably don't know until that that
moment happens how you're gonna handle
it and I think it probably for her came
from knowing that all her you know all
the firefighters that she knew and
worked with and and loved were all in
there were were closer or near the
buildings and and I think she genuinely
wanted to help them and and help get
them out of that situation or help treat
them you know I don't think she I don't
think she ever imagined
that the that the buildings would both
fall you know I think that she didn't
you know she knew they had been hit and
she kind of gradually figured out once
the Pentagon had been hit that it was a
that there was a clearly a coordinated
terrorist act but I don't think she ever
thought structurally something like that
would happen I mean it was so crazy to
start seeing happening because you don't
even when things get hit you know you
just don't expect that to happen so
maybe she you know I don't know that she
ever thought that that I don't think she
could imagine that that would have
happened you know well that chapter
certainly humanized you and your family
in an incredible way because frankly
people look at you and think oh as it
now famous celebrity engaged to a
celebrity and then when you when you
read about your mom rushing towards the
towers the fact that her life was saved
twice by firemen who are it like right
there with her that the people she was
with lost their lives that that day and
then you imagine that you know you and
obviously like you know young people
associate this with with your cast mate
Pete Davidson as well like you realize
that like the human condition like it's
it's your family it's Pete's family it's
the 343 families that got that got
devastated that day who are families of
firefighters and it seems like your
family has so so much of like the
firefighter DNA like in your like your
family's history like I felt like I got
to know you better
as a result of sharing in that
experience it was you know it's such a
kids the community I knew the most and
it was you know like like my grandfather
was a fireman my great-grandfather was a
fireman all my cousins and my uncles
everyone who lives on my the block where
my whole family lived mostly on Staten
Island were all in the fire department
so I knew it forever as this really fun
community of all these like I feel like
firefighters are some of the funniest
people and and really a loving group of
people and then after that there was a
whole other you know obviously element
and he's and it was even more of a
community but in a whole different kind
of way and I thought that one of the
most the things that my mom said that
was the craziest to me was you know when
I when I remember going to visit the you
know Fire Department headquarters where
they have they keep what uh basically a
wall of the names of all the
firefighters who died in the line of
duty and she said that in the first
hundred years of the department they
filled one wall and then that day
on September 11th they filled an entire
other wall like that was that was what
the nut the sheer numbers for the
department were and in Staten Island
obviously including Pete's dad was part
of that wall and a substantial part of
that wall on Staten Island so you know
I'm very proud of my mom and that's why
I wanted to write that chapter and I
really feel for her going through that
and losing colleagues like that now
people I was surprised by so much of
your background because you know I think
that high very high level of you is you
went to Harvard that that's one thing
and you had like a really fun set of
stories about Harvard and so you don't
think oh you know like the mother works
for the fire department
you know grandfather worked it was a
fireman you think like oh he went to
Harvard so you know maybe his parents
were like orthodontist parents were
president and vice president of Harvard
or something yeah or something right
like the week go by and then when you
went to Harvard to like you framed it in
such human terms where like there's like
this hava like mystique and then like
you unpacked it in such a humble way
[Music]
[Applause]
so here in yang speaks we care a lot
about data would think that our data is
getting sold and resold and we're
getting packetized and commoditized
in a way that's really bad for democracy
and mental health a lot of other things
and we're not seeing a dime of it it's a
drag and they're keeping track of
everything we do so what do you do about
it one way to do it is to use Express
VPN and VPN stands for virtual private
network all these high-end companies
insist that their employees use VPNs so
that it's like they're logging into safe
and secure server no matter if they're
at home or at a Starbucks or whatever
the heck it is and you can do the same
thing and this way your Internet
activities anonymous they can't track
you they can't sell and resell it so if
you want to protect your online activity
today with the VPN rated number one by C
net and wired visit expressvpn
dot-com slashing and you can get an
extra three months for free on a
one-year package that's expr ESS VPN
comm slash yang expressvpn dot-com slash
yang to learn more I'm literally using
this right now to stream our podcast ads
in our podcast so it doesn't slow down
your video and audio have no issues with
it
expressvpn comm slash yang get your
discount it's freaking fantastic check
it out
[Music]
[Applause]
so one of your door mates and I became
friendly on the trail Buddha jej and so
how much time did you spend with Pete
when you guys were actually in school
together and then afterwards he I really
I saw him we were in the same dorm for
three years for sophomore junior and
senior year and so he was like roommates
with one of my good friends from high
school and so I would I would see him a
lot and in my friend Rob introduced us
and I would see him at dinner because we
always easily eat in the same place so
so during those dinners did he'd lean
over to you one day and say I'm gonna be
President one day did he do have those
yeah ate like a whole mouthful of french
fries and just stared at me you know
that kind of honestly I would have never
thought that he would be running for
president and but but of course it
things make more sense in retrospect you
know because he was obviously
politically minded and he was stuck I
think he studied government if I'm if
I'm not wrong when he was there or
social studies that included government
but he you know he was always he was
clearly very smart and he was always
really sweet and unassuming and was
never you know talked about some people
who were at Harvard who were really like
trying to make you know they're smart
like kind of showing off which is the
most irritating thing in the world it's
like if you look like if you need to do
that you're probably actually not that
smart
you need to try and prove it to me yeah
or only later like you realize that it's
some horrible insecurity that's related
to or whatever it is but and that you'll
never be satisfied about in some way you
know like you'll always be trying to but
he was not that he was always very
modest yet
you know and those is the kind of person
that clearly is smart but doesn't need
to tell you you know but I didn't know
him I didn't know him well I basically I
saw him around campus and was only happy
to see him but I you know we never
really hung out much except in an
extended group so I'm going to share
something that very few people could
share which is that as a Kennedy when
you see SNL start throwing up that are
big it's like oh my gosh like what are
they gonna do with me that have a you
imitate Pete I thought you did a great
job and that it was really funny like
some of the jokes you actually write in
the book actually you used for your
impersonation of Pete but like so my
question to you was like did you ever
feel like you were being like too mean
did you ever pull it back really like oh
man like that this is actually like
gonna make me feel bad I did and some of
them you know some of the debates I
wrote or co-wrote and others I didn't so
it was interesting because I and that's
typical sometimes in SNL different
people will write different things
obviously but I had never been in I had
never done an impression like that first
of all impression is generous but you
know I had never been in a sketch like
that where it was clearly a lot of
attention on it and on the detail of
what what was being said and I having
written for it but not been in it
previously you instantly feel the
humanity of the person you're doing an
impression of in a way you don't think
about when you're just writing it and
it's really it's like I really wanted to
be careful about it because I wanted to
be fair to Pete and I want it of course
you want to be funny but I know there
were definitely things I I did it I said
no to and cut and and fought against
because I thought they were you know
either not fair or like not you know
like see they're slightly mean or not
thoughtful about who the person was
and by the way Bowen was the same with
you like Ed impersonate he he wanted to
be fair and
always wanted to be fine fun in it but
not be you know tearing you down because
he respected you and and that's that's
typically what it is I mean Maya was
that way with Kamala like she cared
about getting the fine yeah she's so
funny as a performer that she's gonna
find something really funny just on a
pure performance level but you know you
start to think about that and when you
are in more and more in as a person
who's just on the show to a much less
degree in the spotlight you start
realizing how people perceive you or how
people make jokes about you and you're
like oh my god I want to I want them to
feel somewhat true or fair as much as
possible but I'm sure watching it even
something that seems fair might feel
weird or having anyone impersonate use
it must be crazy right you've
experienced in your own way I'll tell
you like hundred percent honest to god I
was just thrilled to be included potater
up there it is his last name's yang like
and so I think someone asked me about
what I thought of
Bowens in-person impression of me or
impersonation and I was like I loved it
it's like you know it's like some some
people you know might have had a bone to
pick but I didn't I was like one just
thrilled that I was included like as
part of the sketch and to you know I
actually had an instinct that Bowen
wanted to be fair like and and
everything that he did I thought was
both funny and fair so I had zero issues
with with how I was presented but I was
just curious in your case too because
it's not like bone and I really know
each other it's not like we went to
college together in that way except for
the way that all all Asians know each
other but you know but in your case you
and Pete like had you socialized again
after college like you'd like seeing him
out of random wedding or need that
jacket you know I had seen him once or
twice like you know I
donated when he ran for for mayor South
Bend because I just you know remembered
like him and college like lady who else
was running but I definitely knew Pete
would be good at it and and then I had
seen him what like somewhere else I
remember someone showed me a photo of
the two of us somewhere like at a
basketball game or whatever was there
somewhere and then when I first started
do like what after the first or second
time I played him on the show he was on
Fallon he was on The Tonight Show which
is obviously like two floors down from
us in the building so I went down and
talked to him and it was bright and I
was happy that he was happy to you know
seemed happy to see me and yeah it was a
real it became such a small world
because obviously he's on a show that's
in our building I was playing him on our
show he was on The Tonight Show and the
other guests on The Tonight Show was
Scarlett so I was like wow this is
really a lot of many different worlds
colliding yeah so that'd be another
level - it's like we actually know the
person you're playing us that'd be like
another level of like like
thoughtfulness where you're like oh snap
I could like this read it to this person
and let you know a little bit down the
road oh yeah so your transition for all
use as an excuse for why I wasn't a
better performer in those moments
because there was so much going on in my
head you know that I'll just put that up
it was such a multi-faceted performance
your God say you like 16 bigs celebrated
very very precisely
[Music]
this is a uniquely and distinctly
stressful anxiety-ridden time for us all
and you got to take care of yourself
right now you have to try and get
exercise and have a routine and get some
structure but even after all that you
know also help is having someone to talk
to and I don't mean like zooming your
buddy and being like hey you know what's
up talking to Zach all the time I mean
like talking to someone about the fact
that that [ __ ] sucks that maybe you know
you're feeling some degree of negative
emotion that it's new to you and I'm
thrilled to say that right now we we
have a new sponsor the podcast better
help calm that will actually hook you up
with therapists and resources online
it's convenient professional affordable
you just find a licensed professional
counselor or who just talk you through
stuff and as usual we have a deal for
you but over a million people are
already using better help
that's heelp calm and if you go to
better help calm slash yang you'll get
10% off your first month by being one of
our podcast listeners so that's better
help a TLP calm slash yang to get
yourself some help and there's
absolutely no shame nothing negative no
stigma about it I mean I I saw a
counselor when I was in high school and
after that I said everyone should have
one of these all the time forever so
yeah get yourself some help it better
help calm slash yang
so we're I'll say in our own
organization Andrew humanity forward
we're now in what month 4/5 of working
from home and I would say the entire
team self included we're all
collectively losing our minds no offense
guys if you're listening but it's true
so I've recommended this to our team and
to use it there because
jeez man like the world's burning we all
have to be stuck inside we have to stare
at screens all day long the lack of like
hope and optimism is something we're
trying to overcome on this podcast but
it's still real so that's better help
hey LP better help comm slashing and get
10% off your first month's and a welcome
you as a Yank speaks listener hope you
guys check it out so one thing that
everyone loves is like the origin story
for everyone you know like you hit the
fast-forward button and someone's like
oh like you know a person's made it
they're successful you do a great job of
actually kind of digging into your
origin story about your time at Harvard
where you just really wanted to work on
the National Lampoon which you got into
or accepted to you after like dozens and
dozens of tries and like a year of
rejection and and the rest of it and
then you came back to Staten Island
lived with your parents right after
college before moving out and then you
worked in journalism as the night editor
of a Staten Island newspaper or the
Staten Island advance and tell us about
that like that the craziest thing to me
was that I think your ship it was like
midnight to 8:00 a.m. which I felt like
would make anyone lose their mind yeah
it was it really was physically pretty
brutal I mean I am up for it when you're
22 you're up 21 20 year of for anything
so I was like yeah gung-ho but after a
few months you can't you can't avoid
your body starting to break down and it
was the worst part by far was commuting
I just moved to the city with a group of
friends and then that was the job I got
back on Staten Island so after commuting
from Staten Island to Manhattan for four
years of high school I finally lived in
the city and started commuting back to
Staten Island for a job and that was I
would be getting on like an express bus
from Staten Island through Brooklyn to
Manhattan at 8:00 a.m. after working all
night with people that were waking up
and commuting like normal people and
that
was really a pretty watching the sunrise
on a bus through Brooklyn is not not the
most fun but that job except for the
hours that job was so fun I loved that
job I was I wrote headlines which is so
fun trying to think of like New York
Post style headlines
I edited articles when there was no one
available to write stories I would fill
in and write stories I wrote a ton of
obituaries which I found like darkly
fascinating I really loved talking to
the families because I really loved the
idea of getting it right like getting
their life story right for their
community who was gonna read about it
like I loved the deep the weird details
of people's lives and kind of teasing
out the fun parts of someone's story
because when if you first talked to a
family they might not give you that they
might be like oh there they were just
like a homemaker they kind of kept to
themselves but if you dig and so many of
these stories there's a fascinating
hobby or some crazy weird period of
their life that they they don't think
about until you start exploring it so um
it was really and it was all so
thrilling to put together a newspaper to
see it in the era where there were still
print newspapers that people read to see
it physically go to the presses and to
hear people yell stop the presses and
mean it like a real thing from a movie
because a story was breaking or whatever
that was really cool
did you ever randomly get to yell oh
stop the presses just just for fun then
someone really would have punched me if
I just did it to yelling no I did not
have that kind of authority well
listening to your enthusiasm for
journalism it sounds to me like there's
at least one point when you thought you
might become a journalist is that
accurate or we I know you were very very
committed to comedy cuz you've been
working on it for years already yeah I
always liked journalism I did it you
know as an intern throughout high school
and I wrote as a reporter as an intern I
wrote for the I wrote I was an opinion
writer like often
writer for the Crimson which is the
newspaper at Harvard for a year but then
it really became so much about friends
and lifestyle and and liking the idea
like being around people who are funny
and having that element of what you're
doing and trying to be funny was just so
intoxicating I think and I I whatever I
did with it whatever my job was gonna be
I knew I wanted to be around people who
were funny and and tried to do comedy in
some way because I I really I just
thought it made life so much better but
who doesn't want to be around people who
were who were funny well I'm friends
with some comedians and I have to say
you seem like one of the best adjusted
comedians I know because it seems like
like comedians I know that's like like
not even that deep under the surface you
like this touch out a little bit but all
of a sudden it's like whoa yeah a lot of
those comedians I am fairly you know
it's taken time you know I work at it I
still have plenty of issues but I work
at it I like go to therapy and work you
know and work at it all the time and you
discover the show Bendis you know you
have to work at you and and it's taken
I'm in such a better place now than I
was 10 years ago five years ago but you
know and I also ignored I I cared so
much about comedy comedy was the thing I
was most serious about by far way more
serious about comedy than I was about
relationships about you know real life
things like I don't know like having a
room that was even livable or you know
having any sort of comforts in life I
all I cared about was comedy so I'm a
collecting a lot of elements in my life
for a long time so I I didn't have I
probably wasn't as unhinged as perhaps
some other comedians are in certain ways
but I had a lot of deep things that I
had to figure out because you know I
to come weirdly into comedy more
seriously than any other part of life
yeah that comes through and you're
really forthright in your book about
like the ups and downs and the
insecurities that come with trying to be
funny and becoming a writer on SNL it
sounds like a very very and is not a
knock I mean you're one of the you know
like the the leaders now of this like
last generation but it seems very much
like a sink or swim type environment
where if someone shows up and they're
not funny for a year they're probably
not gonna be around for a year or two
because none of their writing makes it
on the show or none of their sketches
make it and it sounds like you had a
real adjustment to that that climate
despite the fact that it seemed like you
were like wunderkind like everything
just happened but it seems like there
were some real struggles both while you
were writer and then eventually when you
got more responsibility yeah there you
know there were there were times where
it felt like you're on a roll and things
are going well and then there were real
stretches where you were worried about
getting fired you know I was worried
about getting fired of a bunch of
different summers some as a writer and
some as a performer and you know you
Plan B was always go to the cabin in
Puerto Rico right my plan B you always I
write it out of the book for some reason
I uh I go to Puerto Rico a few times a
year I love Puerto Rico I like doing
like doing fundraisers Puerto Rico I
care a lot about it and I would go my
relatives used to live there and I would
I always fantasize that I could just
disappear to go to like a sleepy surf
town in Puerto Rico get off the grid I
don't even know off the grid as a term I
don't even know what that means or I
don't think that we all know what you
mean I mean for me it's like that
Mexican town and Shawshank Redemption
it's like say Watson a oh say what today
oh so for you it's Puerto Rico yeah I
think we shy when chana and we can
update eventually our last one should be
us on a beach it's a lot today Oh
shawshank style completely totally do
that you know I mean I don't be to get
too into it but like are you guys like a
joint deal where it's like are you like
looking at each other being like you
know when you're done I'm done like yeah
yeah I mean I don't I would never want
to do without him I mean I think he
feels the same way we talked about it
but you know you who knows I don't think
universe would ever begrudge the other
one would ever you know they needed to
do at different times but you know I
would love it would be so nice if we
could continue doing something together
in whatever capacity you know it's uh
its lucky to find you know when you find
someone that you you you both love
working with and you you know you kind
of look up to even though you're working
with them and I would love to continue
that in some way you know yeah you get
into this in the book where they give
you something of like a trial run a
weekend update and then the reviews are
unkind and I actually can relate to
getting beaten up in the press somewhat
and then you're looking up being like
huh like what's happening like this is
reflected on Who I am as a human and
then there's like this somewhere where
the folks at SNL aren't really
communicating with you that much and
then they bring you back in to like
audition for a job that you already had
been filling and then and then and then
they also had Michael che audition and
then eventually they settle on the fact
that they're going to team the two of
you up and now that's been a partnership
that has been incredible for us all to
see in real time grow but can you talk
to a little bit about that summer of
uncertainty yeah I can't it was it was a
rough summer for a lot of reasons and
mainly because you're you're suddenly
being there was the media part of it
that was rough that's one part of it
but the harder part of it was feeling
like all your friends who you work with
we're kind of ghosting you you know like
you know they where no one was actively
being mean or anything but you could
just tell they were kind of like taking
some there's a little bit of pulling
back yeah yeah you do sense that
sometimes saying when they're your
friends you sense it and I know I'm not
like I'm not upset about it I understand
but I could sense that and it's kind of
like um when you I don't know there's a
I always feel like in in the world of
show business when you're not hearing
anything from people it's a bad song and
uh and when you're not hearing anything
from your friends it's like a double
pain because you feel like rejected a
little bit but at your job and you you
feel like you're losing friends and so
you start spiraling and and I didn't
know what was gonna happen because I
thought there was a real possibility
that I was gonna lose my job
a weekend update' and and maybe lose my
job as a writer at the show too or or
sort of be impossible to go back to it
or or not know or feel so broken up by
what happened and I you know and then
your I was used to being in a lot of
meetings where things like this would be
discussed and to be completely in the
dark and all of a sudden they're meeting
about you and you're like I remember
being at the meetings about other people
oh my god and that and then you're like
oh and then also by the way it made me
feel for in a deeper way for everyone
else who were my friends who went
through that process too as cast members
as writers you know like how I remember
Will Forte talking about he didn't know
whether he was gonna get asked that they
keep putting him on like his contract on
extension and not telling him if he was
a gonna continue in the cast one summer
and he was out by where Lauren lives
like he was some coincidentally staying
in a house next to Lauren and he
remembers talking about hiding in the
bushes as he walked around to leave the
house because he was afraid of running
into Lauren and Lauren seeing him and
thinking he was following him and then
firing him because of it and you it
really messes with your mind and you
just don't know you
you're you kind of feel like you're your
career in your life is about to be over
even though that's dramatic it just
feels like that in a moment you're like
oh god I don't know will I work again
will anyone want to hire me you know and
and and again when it's your friends
that's that's the hardest part yeah that
we we can all experience we can all
relate our one like particular version
of that I mean obviously not as public
as you know I will say for me running
for president it was a real education
you know it's like you're on TV all of a
sudden in your case you've been like
writing for a while but you haven't been
as much of a performer and then you get
out there and when you feel like the
public is rejecting or whatever it's
actually like super painful you know
like you because you feel like you're
putting yourself out there and then like
if people don't like it then they don't
like you even though they don't know you
as a person it feels very very personal
and it's different like for me for
instance for you with you as a
presidential candidate I don't remember
ever seeing anything negative about you
like in a great way like I'm not just
saying it enough like I think people had
really thought about you and liked you
and I in my memory the coverage of you
was always really positive and if
anything people were more like wanted
you to be succeeding even more like they
wanted you to be the nominee and they
were really I felt like people a lot of
people were really pulling for you
whereas I'm sure from your perspective a
couple things that are good that people
I'm sure you also have things where
people that were so excited for you when
you started in the meteor so whatever
network outlets in the media then write
something negative or then write
something that feels like almost turning
against you and you're probably like
wait you just were happy or you just
were excited we were we're friends
what's going on like you hung out with
me on the trail for like days right yeah
is it super because you know there's
there's part of it is like you're you're
worried about even how you people better
you know you're you're not always
worried about what the person thinks
that's writing something negative about
you you almost worried like
people you care about in your life will
read it and be like oh yeah Wow I didn't
think about that
he is dad God I do call it but now that
I've read this random review of him like
it's made me think of it totally
differently yeah like it you you do
weird thoughts in your head man you and
if your friend actually did think that
way that would be a terrible friend
and and my friends wouldn't have thought
that as your friends would never thought
that but I'm sure that you kind of go to
those places in your head even though
you shouldn't well call and I had a tip
I have a tip I mean you're now well past
this but I my tip for myself was well I
actually know you you are in the middle
of it because writing a book is very
personal putting the book a book out
there is personal talking about the book
is personal and there are people behind
the book too that you again feel like
you're gonna disappoint you know like
there were folks that supported you in
various ways I went through that with my
first book in 2014 which don't even
remembers honestly so so you so you so I
know you're you're still experiencing it
for sure and everyone watching this you
should know Collins book we are
listening to this Collins book is funny
it's personal it's edifying if you have
an interest in comedy and writing and
humanity it's a great book it's a great
read it's gonna do enormous ly well but
the fact that but the fact that you're
still in the middle of it like people
from the outside looking in being like
Collins on top of the world like you
know he must not have any of these
insecurities that the rest of us have I
you know I feel like I'm in the middle
like I'm you know first of all you feel
like in the middle or or even still at
the beginning of a career and figuring
out so many things and and always always
always worried and scared that I'm not
good enough or I'm losing things that I
liked you know if I'm if I'm not doing
stand-up for a week and now because of
this for months you feel like you're
losing
your your edge of doing it and your
ability to do it and it's kind of a
constant fear of losing that whatever it
is both relevancy but also your just
actual ability of doing it well it's
like a thing you want to always keep
dark you know and and there's so many
things I wanted there's so many things I
want to do and I get very overwhelmed
and often feel like why am I not
accomplishing more why am I not getting
this done back done like huge things
that I'm like this is important that I'm
not I'm like not doing it well you can
be like Michael che and head to this
cornfield in Ohio where they're doing a
live comedy right now talking about that
fine I keep seeing him pictures of him
and Chappelle and Michelle Wolf's and
people like yeah yeah I was joking with
Michelle that like the world capital of
live comedy is that cornfield in Ohio
right now which i think is true the only
place it's an it's incredible
[Music]
okay so if you're like us you listen to
music and maybe you have that headset
but you're noticing some folks around
you have these earbuds or the air pods
of these like wireless things you're
like wow maybe I should get myself some
of those but maybe you're daunted by the
fact that some of them are really
expensive now we were sent some recon
ear buds and they're like the sweet spot
where instead of breaking the bank they
started about half the price of the ear
buds that have been scaring you off you
know I've got a pair right now in my
hand and my ears was one in each it's a
sort of bizarre but they work great they
actually are really snug and indiscreet
like people can't even tell you have
them on necessarily and they're freaking
beautiful stylish celebrities love them
so some of the celebrities that use them
because like I kind of like some of
these people Snoop Dogg cardi B and jr.
Smith you know NBA champion JR Smith use
these ear buds so they are the sweet
spot I'm a fan Rey Khan's ear buds hit
the mark now's the time to get their new
everyday air buds and you can get 15%
off your order at bye recon comm / yang
that's bye recon comm / yang for 15% off
recon wireless earbuds you can join the
future you could be one of those cool
people or annoying people that around
you that have made you feel deficient
soon you will make others feel deficient
at recon comm / yeah I'll say this I've
bought the expensive ear buds and I've
lost them then I feel like I've lost
it's like losing a cellphone
these are not that you you know designed
to lose them but if you do lose them
they're less expensive and with us you
get a pretty good discount so by raking
calm
/ yang get 15% off buy as many as you
can and they sound great great gifts to
greatests yeah give the gift of rake on
[Music]
so one other thing I have in common with
you and Michael che
is that I was a big wrestling fan
growing up and I can tell from your
references that you definitely were too
and then Michael talked you into doing
WrestleMania Oh with it which got you
boys street cred among your like your
high school classmates and everyone else
which I can understand
it'd be like SNL yeah yeah yeah and then
like you're in Wrestlemania I'd be like
holy [ __ ] so you have a very
entertaining chapter about you guys
showing up for Wrestlemania and that but
do you have a story that was either in
or outside the book around that
experience it's fine when you say that
too but you you were also were a debater
so I know I talked about you know speech
into be you were I think doing it on a
higher level I was doing them if I was
doing but I talked about it being the
track and field of uh for nerds like but
you were you were you were at an Olympic
level I would say for among nerds for
the you estimation of the nice of you
yeah of course
and but the debaters that I was friends
with all would go into a hotel room on
tournaments or like speech in debate
tournaments and all the debaters
particularly would reenact wrestling
matches like on the hotel beds but yes
you at the time at wrestling matches and
those were the like really got into it
and those were all the friends that
showed up at WrestleMania and so and I
was like living out there their debate
high school debate hotel bed dreams in
giant Stadium and so it was pretty cool
that they came and were there for it
that was pretty awesome three things
that have a lot in common with each
other in my experience professional
wrestling comedy politics
[Laughter]
I kid you not Colin like weird you're
weird overlaps there huh yeah there are
it's like one reason my Jesse venture
you know became governor and I'm sure
like had world-class potential and
people talked about the rock running for
president he would do great because like
that there were times where like I'd be
at some rally and like they had
something like essentially like bake-off
and they like throw you out there and
you'd be like you have five minutes go
and but like the frame of reference I
used was literally just the pro-wrestler
promo
it actually almost looks like the promos
like back in do you know that when they
do the interstitial promos and wrestling
they have such a political campaign vibe
you know and it's like it's like that
wrestler has that whatever thirty
seconds to get their message out and up
and taught their opponent and set up the
next bit showdown and and it's hey Trump
also appeared on programming for sure so
I'm keeping an eye out for anyone who
tries to cross over from one of those
three to the other because I predict
success but that so that chapter cracked
me up on so many levels because of the
fact that I was such a fan so you talked
about so you like came of age at SNL you
know literally everyone who's come
through when a head writer been on
Weekend Update and the rest of it and
like your book toward the tail end you
talk about this maturation process and
how now you're starting to imagine life
after SNL and it could be that this book
in some ways is like a bit like the
beginning of your thinking about it you
talk also about the fact that now
you know you're just more mature like
you're engaged to be married like you're
more interested in non comedy things in
terms of like spending time with people
so what might the future hold for you
like if you were to leave SNL what would
you want to work on well I would
definitely still it would still be
comedy in in whatever I do I mean you
know there's like a horror movie
I'm kind of working on that I've been
working that I thought about for a long
time but even that has element like big
elements of comedy I got even something
like that I would always it's hard for
me to do something that doesn't have at
least some comedy to it so that's the
the broad answer that it always be
connected to comedy but you know there
there are different kinds of goals
there's writing goals I have their
acting goals that I have and and down
the road there are producing directing
goals that I have well there are
business goals you know like I I'm
fascinated I you know you know it so
well but the business side of so many
things is really fascinating to me and I
love using my brain in that way like I
that that's like a great outlet that I
really that I don't now just have time
to do in the same way I mean there's
always business involved in whatever you
do but you know I like different I get
it man I get it yeah you know and and
seeing something through you know like
you know you've seen you know companies
through and that's them must be a cool
feeling right I mean that must feel like
you know you you build something and
then it keeps going or someone buys it
or you know that must have been those
must be thrilling feelings right yeah
it's very much a creative process Colin
and your instinct around it is spot-on
and I got to say you and other
world-class creatives I know actually
have a lot in common with very
successful entrepreneurs and so the fact
that you're attracted to that makes
perfect sense to me
I think you're gonna be successful at
whatever you do on any of those
dimensions but I I can imagine you be
becoming like a real enterprise builder
production company builder because a lot
of the creative stuff you do it's like
the same stuff it's like you know you
have like a vision you get the pieces
together in your case sometimes it's
just like a sketch but your attitude is
exactly the one you need which is like
okay try it it works it works like you
know like iterate quickly don't take the
failures too much to heart because you
can just get back out there
it
pretty much what entrepreneurship looks
like in many many dimensions I I gotta
say like I love what you do on SNL but
like this guy's a limit for you
afterwards like at the end of your book
actually got me excited about about what
you could sink your teeth into if you
ever decided to leave well thank you
that's very nice I'm you know whatever
business you want to do I'm in we'll do
it we'll split it right down the middle
8020 me and we're in let's do it will
cut Jay in to that way we'll have like
three of the major continents covered
that is like a Latino and like a couple
of other types yes so I'm going to go to
audience questions but I had one
question for you that came up in the
book it didn't come up in the book but
it was a book that came came to mind for
me so you talked about Lauren Michaels
as like this
Godfather figure he has done so much for
so many people for the culture we've all
kind of had our that our upbringing
shaped by Lauren in some ways and it
seems like you and Lauren have developed
like a real respect and admiration like
what happens when Lauren ever decides to
leave I mean he is in his 70s like is
there an heir apparent and I gotta say
reading this book it struck me that you
would be the logical heir apparent
because you've been the head writer you
been a performer like has that ever come
up where Lauren was like you will be the
new Lauren or who's gonna be the new
Lauren does anyone ever think about that
stuff
it definitely has not come up he you
know Lauren is uniquely good at this at
this job and I think has gone through so
many phases of it like from when he
started and what that sort of again
entrepreneurial startup vibe probably
was of that show when it was in this
weird timeslot Saturday night and that
and how cool and scrambling to find it
figure it out was to you know I think
also he probably had very strange
periods of time where he had to probably
even like 80s 90s
kind of thing work yet to fire you know
friends or he had to you know fire
people even let you really liked or had
network battles and you know I bet he's
above and then all the time you know he
also got married had kids you know his
kids grew up he suddenly has people on
the in the show that are younger than
his kids you know like for him he must
have evolved so much as the show went
along there's not been a discussion and
I don't know you know I could imagine
him doing it still for a while longer
he's still really I mean he's there
every day
he's extremely everyone almost people
can't believe he still is he still you
know he still says no to friends
weddings or big anniversary that
whatever things that are important
otherwise his life to be there for the
show
and I don't know you know I and and it's
you know what if I thought about it down
the road the hard thing is it's Lauren's
show so part of me always likes the idea
of doing something new from scratch
after this instead of continuing it even
though I really do love it and I believe
in it as a kind of like concept that
keeps working it's in different ways or
doesn't work and then gets fixed or
needs to be fixed and I think you know a
you know it's it's such a cool place I
have but I do I would be I would kind of
have an itch to start my own thing I
think I I understand that it's very well
and yeah you know Lauren I'll probably
be there until he's like 300 or somebody
like 240 at the anniversary
yeah I know I know oh great yeah I
remember we talked about that
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna talk about something that
you think about every waking moment
stamps maybe not what you get everywhere
every waking moment but you dream about
them but you see you have to mail
something periodically I literally have
to mail something right now and the old
way the twentieth-century way is go to
the post office wait online do all that
jazz so what's the 21st century way
stamps calm you can order whatever you
need you essentially can have a post
office on your phone or computer they'll
even send you a freaking scale if you
set up your account and get discounts of
up to 62 percent this is really just a
smarter way to mail stuff that's
actually just the truth of it we use
stamps calm religiously on the campaign
trail because there was a lot of postage
getting mailed out right now actually
business tip from Andrew yang apparently
right now people are reading their mail
at higher levels than normal so if
you're trying to reach people mailing
stuff is a good idea right now and right
now if you want to sign up for stamps
calm you can get a four week trial plus
free postage and that digital scale I
mentioned without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps calm click
on the microphone at the top of the page
type in yang
let's dance calm and our yang and then
you too can enjoy 21st century
convenience with 20th century post
office goodness
[Music]
okay so we're gonna now take some
audience questions this is a fun one and
you talked about this in the books um
what what is your favorite sketch that
you've written what's my favorite sketch
it's that's what that's a hard question
because there's a lot of there's certain
ones are favorites for different reasons
No
one of my favorites was writing you know
as especially as a character was writing
with with Cecily her as the girl at a
party that you wish you hadn't started a
conversation with that's been like a
ongoing one that I just she's really
such a brilliant performer and writer
too and writing those is really fun and
it feels like a person we all know and I
just felt like it was a good kind of
captured that kind of person well and it
was it was always it was always good to
come back to and actually her her and
Vanessa have these pornstar characters
that are worth something historical
they're so funny those were those are
some of my favorite because they're it's
not that long each one's whatever four
minutes long we've done probably eleven
of them through the years spread out
every different kind of product
placement weird thing in it that we and
I talked about a little bit of book but
they there's so many weird moves in them
that I love like they they have lists of
adjectives they just do and the mad
weird dark stories from their past lives
and then the host is usually a guy
that's also important and always has
some weird vendetta against like someone
high school who said something to them
there's a lot happening in those in
those four minutes so those are really
that's a fun world to start thinking
about like what the hell is this now if
you are a fan of SNL you'll love this
book because Colin goes through a bunch
of his sketches I think something with
the process and it's like a chip dab
every day
you remember like your favorite sketch
that right you know you're like oh like
like the one that made me laugh out loud
in the book there's like the underground
underground music festival sketches like
always like just out the brink of
madness like it does remind you of real
late night stuff you see where you're
like is this for real
oh my god these people are really gonna
get together like that because that is
also really one of my favorites me and
Mike O'Brien or as a writer do this
together and it was like the Insane
Clown Posse
or really do these gathering of Juggalos
no based on and they are and they also
contacted us and like sent us stuff you
know like invited us to go to the real
festival and I was like oh my god
imagine actually going and seeing not
that far off from this crazy thing that
we put out there and being there in
person and that was a little too scary
yeah I can't say I've gone to that level
but I've you know I've been all over the
country and you know I went to like the
first several a Lollapalooza which were
like you know a million times like you
know more legit still like in every
state at this point I did a count
recently and I think I might like 42 or
whatnot they're like eight that there'd
never been a reason to campaign in
because of our messed up system so like
I've never been to the Dakotas I've
never been to like some places like that
that you know they keep me below the 50
but I'm in like somewhere in the low 40s
what was the gate like before you were
running for president where was your
state town at beforehand do you think do
you know or not really it was higher
than normal because venture for America
operated in a dozen cities around the
country including some places I've never
been before venture for America
so Alabama Missouri like a lot of Ohio
Ohio is not that exotic I suppose I
should name a state that
less likely to have gone to ok so I was
I was at Ohio a lot
I'd like I have a lot of friends there
so including Dave Chappelle and like you
know the rest of it I was actually on
the way to visit him when the pandemic
kid I was supposed to go and and that's
why Samantha or Michelle wolf is still
there she went visiting him for like a
benefit and then quarantine happened and
now she's like living in the guest house
we're joking they should name the guest
house after her that's awesome
have you gone no no we should go
together to one of those shows be fine
yeah yeah we should you I'd have to get
yet you know like family approval but
we're joking they should just name it
the Michelle wolf guest house at this
point like five months in a row so I
think I was up like 28 states before the
campaign so I visited another 14 what is
the first thing you're going to do after
the pandemic ends like if there's like
so yeah probably something live comedy
related I'd imagine yes yeah I mean
probably the first thing is gonna be SNL
I would guess or I hope that'll probably
the first thing but I would really love
to trap do some kind of travel you know
we definitely wanted to do some you know
like some kind of you know nice trip at
some point but you know I don't know
when the wedding that will be or where
it can be but I missed that I you know
the other the biggest thing is just
gonna be to see friends I mean I saw a
couple friends that surprised me that
came out and surprised me for my
birthday and it was just the most joy I
felt in so many years seeing really good
friends that you haven't been able to
see and kept like laughing catching up I
can't believe I it's like it's gone so
long you forget how good it feels
Wow we can all relate to that
I mean I have a niece that I didn't meet
for like the first six months of her
life because my my brother was very like
you know like
cautious would you understand you're
like yeah I get it but then the other
hand you're like you know like come on I
want to be my feet by these so let it go
you know so when it would eventually
happen like I felt some version of the
joy you're talking about we all miss it
man we all miss each other hopefully
this book talk is a simulation of the
human contact that we all miss much like
human contact yeah yes wait we should do
a service that's a good commercial
parody that we could write like FedEx
for nieces you haven't met where they'll
FedEx the nice to you you can say hi
FedEx FedEx your fax or back you know
we're good yeah like make sure she's
like wrap did bubble wrap so like I've
gotten like you know you know some of
friends sent us steaks for Peter you
know you know you can probably send a
nice I'll figure it out yes about
commercial parodies the the real
logistics don't have to don't have to
make sense you just like magic
oh actually you probably had a hand in a
lot of these what's your favorite
commercial parody that you had a hand in
writing like did you write some of those
yeah one of my one of my favorites
whatever is this one it was called red
flag perfume with Kristen Wiig right
yeah with Kristen Wiig that was one of
my favorites because I she was like curb
you know she was so great at it it was
like it was like the prime of her SNL
career and it was like the first
commercial parody of the year and I G
was like just fun to think about what
are the kinds of things that are red
flags she's lived in Las Vegas for ten
years your nail that's way longer than
the RAF's things like that it was a
really fun and she was just so you know
it's so good if it looks adding other
kinds of visual elements to it that I
hadn't even thought of but it looked
beautiful it looked like a real great
perfume commercial our director Rhys
Thomas tried and it was like I remember
filming down at the like an old
courthouse building or something down by
Wall Street that just was this beautiful
wood panel
a space in New York that is so gorgeous
and you've never heard of it or seen it
and so it also took me down there it was
like such a wonderful shoot and I
thought it came together well yeah those
are the best parodies where you're
looking at it being like is this real
like it seems like so well done it takes
a should have salted perfume yeah you
left some money on the table there that
would be like your first foray and ran
them up rid of household fragrances and
you're gonna do it by the way when you
after quarantine do you know I mean
right now I'm focused on helping go in
and then hopefully being in position to
help dig us out of this hole so right
now I expected to be campaigning for Joe
but as it is is just like beaming into
stuff which I I will confess given that
like my kids we're starting to forget
what I looked like down the stretch of
the campaign like it's had its silver
lining because you know like I thought
I'd be in Milwaukee like and Michigan
and Pennsylvania and the rest of it by
now so after quarantine ends I'm sure
like I'll be out there because you know
it's all hands on deck there's a dark
time and I think Joe's gonna win but
like then that's just like the starting
gun of this epic amount of work we have
to do yeah it's a pretty crazy I you
know I mean it's amazing it's like every
week you see we say to ourselves I can't
how I can't believe it got worse but it
keeps getting there's so many other
things that keep happening like wow and
I do feel like you're you know just even
your your your other book the war of war
on normal people is a real thing it's
gotten that's gotten even worse to like
the the overlooking so many people and
that are in need of basic you know in
need of a basic income or an economic
opportunity like that's God
even worse among all the others among
the big giant problems that real basic
life you know an economic opportunity
has gotten worse which is that's the
thing that was kind of the one thing
people thought they'd get out of you
know having Trump in office and that's
gotten worse so you're like what what is
what is in it with you know what's in it
for Americans now that's what I don't
thinking like what's the upside it's one
reason why I think Joe's gonna win that
72% of Americans say this is the worst
time in American history in our
lifetimes I mean that's not exactly like
four more years material like this is
freaking awful so I think you know I
think we're gonna call an end to the
Trump era but then the whole still gonna
be there so you know I just I haven't
liked my shovel in my closet before
eclis speaking and I'm just like waiting
to buy the word to go out and and start
digging here I got just to speak to that
since it's right here hold on I've got E
where is it is a literal trowel that I
was using to dig in the backyard for
treasure so you know in the woods so
that's where I'm at
that's a very lethal looking trowel you
know I yeah I missed it where are you
physically right now Colin out in Long
Island like a Eason lon you know it's
great so the last audience question
we're going to get to I think it's
interesting
is um and I hope you understand what
this means more than I do because I just
have a vague sense but I think you
probably will with Gen Z humor being
different from that of other generations
what do you think the future of comedy
will look like especially for shows like
SNL I thought this would be a good way
to and that's a great question yeah you
know I love I'm technically a millennial
but so I I feel like I'm but I grew up
really knowing Gen X the most I would
say like that was a lot so much of my
influence so I have a lot of the desire
to do everything
Millennials but I have a lot of the
self-doubt and self-hatred of Gen X so
I'll have an idea like oh I want it I
could do that and then I'll be like no
you can you know I'm in that combo world
but I think I think it will you know I
think every generation finds their own
comedy the way they find their own music
and you know I now in my life I never
want to look back and say that music
sucks or that comedy sucks because I
remember how many people said that about
comedy I loved or music I loved and now
you know people or look back at some of
those things as classics you know and
you know think about like Jim Carrey and
his early movies were some of the most
meaningful movies that I saw like Ace
Ventura and Dumb and Dumber and you know
every those were it's not like those
were well reviewed but they were so
influential for you know at least a
generation and I think that's gonna be
the case comedy will find what that is
exactly and we might not really know
what it is now but at the end of the day
funny is funny you know like people who
are funny things that make you laugh
make you laugh and there are there are
not as many people doing that as you'd
think like when you start out you're
like this probably millions of people
that are really funny and then millions
after a while you're like it might be or
100 or so yeah just as you you know when
you think about business or you think
about certainly politics so you know you
and your mind universe shrinks very
quick oh my god and you're actually like
there's so few people I trust or so few
people I think are are good at this and
actually you know you find people in
across fields actually who you recognize
as oh they're really smart and good even
though I don't totally know their world
you know you see their you see them and
you see their talent even if it's not in
the field you're in and I don't know
that I
think I think comedy will keep evolving
it will go through cycles you know it
will maybe it feels for some people to
feel sensitive that will correct and be
way the other way and you know breaking
up that and I think it'll it'll it'll
keep evolving and I'm excited to see
where so many people are pessimistic
about comedy but I also think there's so
many really bright you know funny
comedians working right now who are
gonna get more and more of a voice and I
think that's great well whatever the
future of comedy is you're gonna have a
huge role in it let's give colin jost a
huge round of applause everyone going
out I think most of you have already
bought his book by virtue of being here
tonight but read it spread the word a
very punchable face is a very enjoyable
book I'll put a paperback maybe on the
paper bag you could definitely use that
for the paperback which this will
definitely be printed in before very
long so thank you all for being here
thank you for 6:00 and I colin is such a
pleasure all the best to you and the
family
congratulations on a massive achievement
it's something you should be really
really proud of and I know how much work
goes into it I know how much you invest
personally now you should be really
proud thank you thank you again for
doing this and I am very excited to see
your future and and I and I thank you
for doing your part and I hope you're a
big part of this next administration so
I appreciate it thank you
thank you for listening in I hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notification so we can let you
know every time we have a new episode